i'm wrong by the way from weasley
there are underrated characters and then
there's ron weasley
someone who had all of his potential
snatched away
literally when you hear ron weasley you
probably think harry's best friend and
hermione's love interest
that's because the harry potter film
stole all ron weasley had to offer
including his actual lines let us show
you
that was clever ron that's been known to
happen one thing that always set ron
weasley apart from his friends was
his knowledge of the wizarding world i
know what that is
that's an invisibility cloak harry and
hermione were both raised by muggles and
fascinated by everything magical
just like how mr weasley didn't quite
get rubber ducks tell me
what exactly is the function of a rubber
duck
oh um but the movies never really showed
that advantage he had over the duo
instead the moments where he would shine
in the novels were given as lines to
characters like hermione to show her
intelligence
remember when malfoy insults hermione by
calling her a mud blood in the chamber
of secrets
no one asked your opinion you filthy
little mud blood
just like harry we have no idea what
that actually means until he asks in
hagrid's hut
in the novels ron is the one to give
harry an answer but in the film
hermione is the one to spit out the
definition mud blood's a really foul
name for someone who's muggle-born
someone with non-magic parents someone
like me
she does read a lot but this definitely
should have been a line ron got to keep
it just made sense
everyone knows that hermione loves to
share her knowledge with others or be
the one to explain something
it's part of her charm no matter what
snape thinks
put your hand down you silly girl
however in the movie they took her
excitement of knowledge to the point
where it left ron
in the shadows the order of the phoenix
doesn't kick off at hogwarts
instead we get to see the golden trio
reunite at grimmeld place
but ron and hermione had been keeping
some very big secrets about the order
and voldemort from their friend
and when ron begins to explain the
reason behind their secrecy hermione
interrupts with her own explanation
we wanted to write mate really we did
only only what only dumbledore made i
swear not to tell you anything
in the books it's all ron who gives
harry the reason and apology
it's not a huge moment but it's
definitely a moment where they stripped
away ron's true character
harry figures out pretty fast that he
won't be attending his final year at
hogwarts
instead he'll spend the year hunting the
horcruxes that make up voldemort's soul
at the end of half-blood prince harry
and hermione have a heart-to-heart on a
hogwarts balcony where she assures him
they'll be by his side the entire way
i don't really think you're going to be
able to find all these horcruxes by
yourself do you
you need us harry if you're like us
you're probably wondering why ron wasn't
included in this conversation
well the truth is he was in the novels
in fact he's the one who tells harry
we're with you whatever happens
why would they take such an emotional
moment away from ron this line would
have shown how much ron cared for his
friends
we're a sucker for any best friend to
love her trope including ron and
hermione but we're just gonna put it out
there
their relationship was definitely
sidetracked when the books were
translated on screen
their relationship was anything but
obvious we didn't even get a hint that
ron liked her until the yule ball in the
goblet of fire
but the same can't be said for book
hermione ron was defending her even when
they were still
children there's a point in prisoner of
azkaban during the page 394 scene
turn to page 394
where ron defends hermione after snape
calls her insufferable
know it all in the movies ron actually
agrees with snape
and snidely tells her he's got a point
you know
seriously are these two runs even the
same character harry hermione and ron's
first adventure together is a memorable
one
they play a wild game of wizards chess
fly to find a magic key
and get trapped in some devil's snare
however there's a major difference
between the book and movie versions of
this adventure
ron's bravery sure in the movie he takes
on the life-size game of chess and
stride but when they get themselves
stuck in the devil's snare it's all
pleased for help from ron
it's definitely understandable but
disappointing when you remember how he
actually responded in the novels ron is
actually the one to comfort a panicked
hermione enough to remind her that she
is a witch with powers
that gets her brain gears going and she
saves the day
stop moving both of you this is devil's
snare
you have to relax it would have been
nice to see this kind of teamwork
between them happen on screen
ron even got his lines about scabbers
taken away from him
the golden trio gets a shock of their
lives when they discover the truth about
serious black
but also the truth about scabbers ron's
12 year old rat
is actually peter pettigrew the man who
betrayed harry's parents
in the books the three attempt to
explain to their headmaster exactly what
went down at the whomping willow and in
the shrieking shack
including scabber's transformation ron
is the one who has the honor of spilling
the tea to dumbledore scammers who did
it
scabbles he's my rat sir he's not really
a rat
well he was a rat however in the movies
they make it seem as if ron is unable to
even form a proper explanation
instead hermione jumps in and steals his
line again
then they gave him an hour because we
know the truth
please believe us it seems like a lot of
the films used ron moore's comedic
relief
instead of the epic character he was
meant to be
speaking of this shrieking shack scene
things get pretty heated in there
ron with a very hurt leg harry convinced
he's about to die
and hermione's stepping in to be the
fearless witch she is
she even steps in front of harry and
offers herself
up before sirius has the opportunity to
hurt harry
if you want to kill harry you'll have to
kill us too but that's not how it went
down at all
in the books any guesses of what
actually happened
that's right hermione was once again
given a moment
to shine that was originally meant for
ron in the book
ron drags his hurt body in front of his
best friend
and proclaims not once but twice that
sirius would have to go through
him before he got to harry we're
starting to realise more and more
that ron being sorted into gryffindor in
the films doesn't even make sense
despite the fact that he's a weasley of
course we have the scene in the chamber
of secrets where harry and ron follow a
line of spiders
in order to get some information and
save hermione
you probably think back on that scene as
a humorous one especially because of
ron's iconic line
why spiders why can't we follow the
butterflies
which of course is hilarious but his
fear and hesitation to head into the
dark
forest is anything but accurate during
this moment in the books
ron is so quick to put his fear behind
him he's so determined to help hermione
adding this scene in the movie would
have not only added to his overall
character but would have shown
how much he cared for her even when they
were just 12 years old
welcome back hermione it's good to be
back
remember this line even in the wizarding
world hearing voices isn't a good sign
it's what hermione tells harry when he
questions whether he should open up
about the voices he's hearing from the
chamber of secrets
let's talk about this for a second the
line sounds like it would come from
someone who had
experience in the wizarding world
someone who had grown up surrounded by
magic not someone who has only been in
the wizarding world for less than two
years
basically someone like ron and in the
books that was his line
his exact line was hearing voices no one
else can hear
isn't a good sign even in the wizarding
world hermione stole his line basically
word for word
by watching the films you've probably
come to the conclusion that ron is
pretty oblivious to a lot of things
happening around him
like when he couldn't understand why
hermione was upset about lavender
but he isn't meant to be completely
clueless especially when it comes to his
best friends
in both the book and movie harry endures
some pretty bad
discipline techniques from umbridge
where he's literally forced to carve the
line
i must not tell lies into his hand but
being harry he wasn't going to tell
anyone
except he couldn't keep his secret from
wrong book ron notices the scar
basically the next time he sees him
however in the order of the phoenix
movie
it's hermione who notices and makes a
big deal about it
what's wrong with your hand nothing
not gonna lie we're more than a little
upset at how many iconic lines were
stolen from ron weasley
the movies made him almost
unrecognizable in comparison to the
character jk rowling wrote him to be
if he kept these lines he might have
been even more popular than hermione
how do you feel about how they portrayed
movie ron let's discuss down below
make sure to hit that subscribe button
and give this video a like we wouldn't
want you missing out on all the things
has to offer
thanks for watching